Let's go next to a Tristin from Kansas
City, Missouri. Treston, you're on the air.
Hi, David. Can hear
me. Yes, I can.
OK, good. So I actually I actually climbed up the
pipeline to the convert myself from the stage of
conspiracies. Mm hmm. So in twenty sixteen I was
basically q8 on before going went on was a big
thing really. Like what were your beliefs. Well
I found some YouTube conspiracy theorists that
basically said that Obama was going to declare
martial law and all that crap. Yeah, he was going
to lock all the Christians of FEMA camps and they
showed all this, quote unquote, evidence that,
you know, that pizza parlor in Washington, D.C.,
I thought that before it was even less popular.
Now, let me ask you this. This is super
interesting. Let's take one of those, which is
Obama will lock up Christians in FEMA camps.
When you fell for that, did you actually go
through in your head like, OK, what would be the
authority that comes up to do the locking up?
How would they identify who is Christian like
that? You did you think in that level of detail?
Well, there was there was a big theory that the
whole world was behind it. It was like a secret
cabal. And they have everybody's informations,
you know, based on your Internet history,
if you're like a Christian. So they would come and
they would take away all the people who qualify
under a specific criteria. Right. And it's a
real mess. My whole reason for coming on here is
to tell you that there are more people like
that. And you think you go to, you know,
to find a radical leftist. It's really
hard to find. You could probably find
some at some college campuses. But I swear to
God, these people, these crazy Kuhnen people,
they exist at every single dollar store you go
to. Right. Right. And I want to know, David,
if you how you handle all of this, how you handle
all this insanity, does it keep you up at night?
Do you are you, like, nervous for our future?
Because the more the further we get into this
and the further we get into seeing
our climate getting destroyed and
all of this information come. Does it ever
scare you for the future knowing that more
and more people are losing their minds?
Well, listen, the only if you're paying
attention and you're not scared, then you're
not understanding. Right. But I do think that,
you know, applying stoic philosophy is relevant
to understand the limits of what you can control.
I can work to inform people about what's going on
with the climate. But ultimately, I can't control
the outcome of whether we deal with climate. So
I really do try to remind myself that there's not
much use in worrying about things that are beyond
my control. I can certainly do my best to inform
and I can control that. But ultimately, a lot of
these issues are bigger than any one person. And
so I think it's important to bear that in mind. I
take weekends off from the news and from politics,
and I think that scheduled breaks are also
good. But yeah, if you're paying attention,
you and you understand what's going
on. Of course, you would be worried.
OK, thank you, David. That that pretty much I
just wanted to know what was going on behind
the scenes with
Now Treston,
how what happened that you stopped believing this
crazy conspiracy stuff? What got you out of it?
Well well, it's funny. Most people talk about
the ultraright pipeline, how people, you know,
climb down this rabbit hole to find crazy
ideologies. For me, I it was it was spiritism.
And then I found an episode of Joe Rogan talking
Alex Jones, and that actually introduced me to
Joe Rogan. I started watching him and then he
had on a few progressives. I watched Jay Kirk,
the amazing atheist, and he he he like debunked a
lot of these conspiracy theories. And then there
I found secular talk and now I'm listening, you
and Varsh and people who would be considered more
on the far left end. But I'm very skeptical
with that, too. I try not to fall down any
more rabbit holes of fringe ideologies. I try to
keep it pretty neutral most of the time. Well, it
seems like you have a framework now where anything
you hear, you will then evaluate for yourself and
and research further rather than taking anyone's
word for anything which seems. Of course.
Yeah, of course. I've I've
learned my lesson from that.
Treston, congratulations.
Thank you, David. All right.
There we go. Very, very important
stuff. Extremely important stuff.